thank you
[Music]
guys know about street takeovers right
yeah yeah yeah getting pretty sick of
them what do you think I'm not really
around them but
um Gilbert our friend Gilbert has them
outside of his [ __ ] house because he
lives in that area where they like yeah
yeah well they do takeovers a lot on
this corner bro like he'll just look out
of his window and then they're just like
and it's like everyone has other people
like yeah recording what do you think
would happen if he starts throwing
fireworks down there like you think
they'll just go yeah yeah probably I've
seen some crazy videos where this guy
was standing on a light pole and with
like a cement base and this charger or
Challenger it's usually one of those
Challengers or Chargers drives right
into it looked like he was trying to hit
him and crash right so I was like oh
this is like craziness does that happen
all the time I take over dude there's
worse [ __ ] no there's a funny one do you
see do you see the one where a car ran
over a dude but all it did was rip off
his pants yeah and ran over his legs and
then the spinning tires took his pants
and underwear off
but people are getting bashed all the
time whenever the cops arrive they just
do it in circles around them the only
thing this is probably the thing I hate
the most about them is that it just
blatantly exposes how unequipped our law
enforcement is to even have a chance of
dealing with it every single time the
cops are just get they just get water
throwing them laughed at they can't do
nothing because mostly people under age
too yeah I'm surprised that
so like this would have never [ __ ]
happened in my teens
when cops come through dude they're
ground
accepted back then but now they're
against it well yeah because back then
it was like oh if you if you got beat up
by a cop you probably [ __ ] up somehow
but I missed police brutality I think I
just feel like it's not fair that I had
to go through something completely
different than these [ __ ] because
that looks really fun as a team yeah
that's what I look my teen brain is like
you're a bitter OG just like all the
people I'm absolutely staring like
because if that's our generation the
cops would already falling in the like
Riot people tear gas [ __ ] bean bags
like shotguns like the highest form of
non-lethal force would have been used
but then now they got like all these PR
issues they have to deal with so they
like immediately they would do it yeah
I've seen cops get [ __ ] taunted with
like he's about to wrestleman he runs
off and another person
I never would have saw that dude it's
it's crazy because uh
the laughable headline right now is that
LAPD has decided to have a zero
tolerance policy
[Music]
used to be crazy dude they really can't
do and it's not I'm not like saying it's
lapd's fault it's the state's fault for
making their efforts nullify oh they cut
off the [ __ ] arms and hands and Dick
if they arrested every single person at
a takeover they would have to let him go
right away like it's not gonna stick
Plus on the other side of that they're
now saying they're gonna start
impounding all the cars even the
spectators how they don't got enough tow
trucks but I bet you all the Armenians
right now are like oh buddy let's do it
because the main the main reason with
these takeovers and anything of that
nature is that when they try to disperse
the crowd is more danger potentially
happens because that's all everybody
yeah there's been lots of situations
where people fleeing takeovers have been
killed there's been accidents or been
all kinds of stuff and recently there
was that takeover where all the people
from the Takeover uh or a shitload of
them rush into a 7-Eleven and just
looted the [ __ ] oh yeah I saw that it's
like they're seeing in Fast and the
Furious remember when the cops come and
then all the cars just [ __ ] yeah
exactly but look at how
just like um and I'm just speaking out a
turn here but can't they just [ __ ]
you know on the side just wait at the
end of the day because they're not
trying to like kill a bunch of people
obviously it's not it shouldn't be
acceptable all the time but can't they
just like take notes write down all the
[ __ ] license plates or film
everything and stuff like that and then
instead of thinking like put them in
jail but then you can't hold him and
just hit him you have to let them go
can't they just put up some ridiculous
fine for this type of crime but that's
not the issue the half of the battle is
the pr issue right so you have a cop
showing up there he's writing notes the
guys still continuing with donuts now
everyone is going oh my God the police
don't even care and that becomes this
becomes a nightmare they should just
like but that's how they don't show up
so they just don't show up that's what
I'm saying they just don't show up you
take [ __ ] photos of everything and
everybody who's there everybody's got a
photo when they find them later they
give them like a three thousand dollar
fine for being there this is what they
do I figure it out because as a kid if
you get fined like a thousand dollars
that your life is [ __ ] you know what I
mean while they're doing the takeovers
but our D.A likes this stuff the police
needs to creep up and just throw those
Rumble what are those called the strips
oh yeah they just gonna surround the
area with strips so when they drive off
the reason the reason they can't do that
is because they they're not allowed to
let these people even get hurt that's
the thing if they get hurt because of a
cop putting strips out here yeah because
then they would just boost it's like so
fast yeah Fast and Furious was like it's
a movie right like but there were that
came from our [ __ ] generation right
so like but when it happened in Our
Generation all I [ __ ] remember is
when cops came someone was gonna get
[ __ ] because that was their [ __ ] it's
like one of us is gonna get [ __ ] right
and then they do [ __ ] Corner box they
take cars down they take any human being
that they can take and then we all hear
about it oh you heard about so-and-so
they took his car they [ __ ] did this
to him who's gonna [ __ ] have to deal
with so much [ __ ] and then little by
little everyone got scared to go out and
race I'm surprised no one's like bought
up like a bunch of land and just like
put Road in there and then like they
made it a designated spot Oh Come dude
they tried to help [ __ ] they try to help
that situation by opening up some of the
Speedways to straight up take over style
me it's but it's not the same so it's
not to say because it's not illegal the
illegal thing is the fun part this so
here you guys know what Bots dots are
Bots and Knots Bots dots no no I know it
is the dumbest [ __ ] solution they
came up with to try to to fix this so
they put this in the popular
intersections in Compton where people
were doing uh street takeovers it's
pretty much just those bumps in the road
you know those little yellow like turtle
shells so they put a bunch of those
[ __ ] cars up I hate like at the gas
station I don't realize how fast let's
see how Bots Dodge did in this Zero
Tolerance it's called why do they call
that but dots aren't stopping Street
takeovers in Compton
they just use the best
this is what it looked like overnight at
Central and Alondra the drivers getting
in circles to a crowd of Spectators they
did this for more than an hour and later
the same thing happened at Bots dots
intersection at Wilmington and college
it's another only doing it just stopped
the tires from spinning Compton has
spent more than four thousand dollars
installing them on four different
intersections
good job guys I thought they were like
you know at the gas station where the
floors like all misleveled and it's like
big things that's what I thought those
were I didn't realize those little
yellow things [ __ ] you gotta you gotta
earn their respect you know when you got
like skaters and [ __ ] right and the cops
come hey you can't skate here whatever
when the cop goes let me let me see this
skateboard let me see let me get this
game
oh the cop gotta get it
he's got to join in dude it wasn't all
respect dude if you can't beat him you
gotta join them bro oh [ __ ] and then and
then if the cop beats you they get your
pink slip yeah yeah yeah
bring up the [ __ ]
the cops doing it
the prison bus yeah you gotta earn the
respect I think Bart's onto something
they gotta try that out because the Bots
dots whatever those [ __ ] names are
ridiculous Name by the way or what if we
just totally embrace the culture like
like police brutality culture
we had guns pulled on us out of nowhere
I was about to go home do you feel like
that helped you be a better person here
honestly it gave me a respect for
authority but do you think fear for
Authority not respect I [ __ ] hated
cops Where's the Line Where's the Line
how much is too much police brutality
well the the videos that we see those
are no good oh yeah if there's like four
dudes jumping a dude I don't like that
yeah I don't like that we just gotta
figure out the line you know what I mean
put too much police brutality would be
like the tragic cases that we see we're
like like people die and [ __ ] and all
that it's like a little like but to be
honest though as a former [ __ ]
dumbass like the general organ if the
cops were too easy I would [ __ ] go
even harder and that's why we see this
happening no I agree I agree it seems
like it's such a futile thing especially
if they're saying zero tolerance means
we're gonna impound everyone's cars it's
like dude these guys are driving their
beaters that they're crashing into each
other it's not gonna kill them that
you're taking a competition does not
even registered or plated It came it
just doesn't seem like there's real fear
or Consequences that's the main thing is
that like if you get caught nothing's
really going to happen to you and I
think that's where the [ __ ] problem
lies so what do you think would be the
solution they can't just find these
people like a good amount of money
they'll just never pay it well the da
isn't pressing charges on anything so
they're they're not even going to find
anybody because I mean if they're
letting violent like Crooks go this is
the least of their problem yeah if
they're out there doing [ __ ] Asian
hate [ __ ] beating up grandmas all day
and then they're like you could keep
going out and beat up more like come on
dude like takeovers is the least of
their problem we had a cop come into the
store that I that I work with sometimes
and he told us that in in a span of
three weeks he had arrested the same guy
three times but he just keeps getting
out like they'll take him in and then
he'll immediately get out yeah I've
heard this by so many like officers not
just in California but the more blue
States there's a policy going on that's
more about trying to be reformed right
so so they'll catch people and they're
doing their job catching people yeah but
the prosecutor isn't putting them in and
and like and like putting them to court
they're not they're not Prosecuting
they're they're not doing their job
because they feel like oh no we need to
reform but then they're like well then
create a reforming program don't just
say they don't need to go to jail
because we need a reform that is a
reforming program yeah that's the thing
that sucks is that now it's like La has
this reputation of total lawlessness in
a way and uh it feels like Gotham yeah
it kind of does cool Gotham
but that's that's the funny that's the
funny joke and kind of the sadness about
hearing La say we're taking Zero
Tolerance policy it's like okay nice
bumps on the road by the way okay
Commissioner Gordon I'm down if the
police tag team the [ __ ] fire
department and they come and they just
blast them with the hose
that'll be tight
and they're just like
hit the guy that's swinging out oh
[ __ ] they get their cars all wet
especially after they like just wash
their car
and then they have Mike Tyson come
through with like a thousand pigeons and
they just [ __ ] everywhere
that's good
that's really good
[Music]